North Korea has unveiled a host of new
weapons in recent weeks
they include a tactical nuclear warhead
an underwater drone
and a solid field intercontinental
ballistic missile
the significant advances in pyongyang's
arsenal were a major focus of President
Biden's latest talks with his South
Korean counterpart I'm used to defense
treaty
is Ironclad and that includes our
commitment to Extended deterrence
and uh and uh that includes the nuclear
threat and the nuclear deterrent we look
at what Pyongyang said the newest
weapons are capable of and how they add
to the growing threat from North Korea
in late March North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un ordered the expansion of
weapons-grade nuclear material to boost
the country's Arsenal that same week
State media released photos showing Kim
inspecting weapons including what North
Korea calls the hwasan 31 it was the
first time Pyongyang provided evidence
to back its claim that it has tactical
nuclear warheads that could be mounted
on its missiles
by the beginning of April Pyongyang said
an underwater drone it tested twice is
capable of conducting nuclear attacks
referring to an earlier exercise State
media said the Drone could trigger a
quote radioactive tsunami
on April 13th in another first
Pyongyang launched a solid fueled
intercontinental ballistic missile
experts said if this solid fuel
technology is perfected the long-range
weapon can be deployed faster and is
harder to detect the missile traveled
for more than 600 miles before landing
in waters east of the Korean Peninsula
the U.S and the UN condemned the test
the Secretary General reiterates his
call on the Democratic People's Republic
of Korea to fully comply with its
International obligations under all
relevant Security Council resolutions to
reopen Communications channels and to
resume dialogue leading to sustainable
peace and the complete and verifiable
denuclearization of the Korean peninsula
North Korea said the launch was part of
its response to consecutive joint
military drills between the U.S and
South Korea
less than a week after the launch
Pyongyang said it finished building the
country's first spy satellite which is
aimed at collecting real-time
information on the U.S military and its
allies
shortly after State media released
photos of Kim and his daughter visiting
the country's space agency he ordered
the launch of the satellite without
giving an exact date
welcome to the White House
on April 26th South Korean president
Yoon so kyol met with President Biden in
the U.S both leaders vowed to take
overwhelming action if North Korea
launches a nuclear attack
the Allies will set up a group to share
information on nuclear operations and
planning in the U.S we'll send strategic
assets to South Korea regularly
experts said the latest spree of missile
launches and display of new technology
show North Korea's weapons program has
made rapid gains and the advances are
expected to continue
foreign